recibir el protocolario beneplácito de
la Reina Isabel II Es un honor para mí
asumir esta responsabilidad en un
momento vital para nuestro país así se
presentó frente al número 10 de Downey
in Street la nueva primera ministra de
Reino Unido la conservadora listros
dirigiéndose al pueblo británico con un
discurso breve y contundente y la
intención de capear la tormenta
económica que atraviesa la isla con una
reforma radical tengo un plan Audaz para
hacer crecer la economía mediante
recortes y reformas Fiscales reduciré
los impuestos para compensar el trabajo
duro e impulsar el crecimiento y la
inversión impulsados por las empresas
trans parece seguir la línea neoliberal
del saliente Boris Johnson y afronta el
reto de hacer frente a la crisis
energética y el desbordado costo de vida
así como un desgastado sistema de salud
me ocuparé directamente de la crisis
energética causada por la guerra de
Putin tomaré medidas esta semana para
hacer frente a las facturas de energía y
para asegurar nuestro futuro suministro
de energía
pondremos nuestro servicio de salud en
una base firme la primera ministra se
enfrenta también a la profunda división
de los Stories de su partido por ello ya
inició el nombramiento de nuevos
ministros afines como ven Wallace como
ministro de defensa o suela breverman
como ministra del interior
no debemos dejarnos amedrentar por los
retos a los que nos enfrentamos por más
fuerte que sea por muy fuerte que sea la
tormenta sé que el pueblo británico es
más fuerte el miércoles tras se reunirá
junto con su nuevo equipo ante el
consejo de ministros antes de su primera
comparecencia en el parlamento
[Aplausos]